[Music]
Brianna wants to show you how to put
your best face forward and only we've
got her good girl gone bad beauty tips I
want to give you guys a vibe my vibe for
summer is more is more a step-by-step
guide on how to look more like RiRi
first you gotta have the right tools
Brianna of course uses Vinci beauty fat
phase and your cheeks looking like baby
cheeks
steve is golly see that look next the
makeup must have in her bag her bold red
lipstick I started getting in trouble
for a red lipstick too early in my
career and now it's like guys the limit
no rules I could do whatever it was
[Music]
we're step three we went to reread
makeup artist Priscilla oh no it's
actually matter on the set of one of her
music videos and I'm actually in it's
called SNM because I'm gonna take a
little bit of our eyeshadow primer I'm
just gonna dab it on the lid
Priscilla showed us how to recreate the
makeup Rihanna wall for the London
premiere of oceans 8 everyone was asking
what is she wearing on the eyes and we
couldn't say cuz we hadn't launched it
bring it up and then into the crease to
lift the eyes and make them look
lifted well now Rihanna's Moroccan spice
collection is launching use the bronze
and gold tones to look sunkissed
line the lip then fill it in her palate
has a color called evil genie inspired
by Rihanna's wild thoughts makeup in her
video when I was Jo get it but the best
beauty tip we got from Rihanna her step
I'm very realistic when I look in the
mirror like I know I'm in shape out of
shape if I got it but is what it is you
without dark circles I just wear more
makeup all women deserves to feel
beautiful
[Music]